à l'époque de
pasteur
vous avez des relations homosexuelles
avec Gérard Jugnot
le pire est à venir Thierry Lhermitte
est-ce que vous savez mentir oui bien
sûr moi pas du tout je dis toujours la
vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès qu'il y a pas d'affiche un bonheur
cette émission
il y a des baffistes au Mexique c'est
insensé j'ai reçu un email non non pas
lui mais il y a des baffistes des gens
qui regardent l'émission au Mexique qui
bougent pendant le jingle et qui c'est
insensé cette histoire alors
à l'époque de de pasteur
vous avez des relations homosexuelles
avec Gérard Jugnot
oui
vous avez décidé de faire un petit essai
tous les deux à nouveau ensemble
il veut pas alors voilà le problème
je pense qu'il faut rien éperdu je te le
dis je te le dis genre je suis encore là
et je crois que je t'attendrai toute ma
vie
bien
Thierry tail on continue
donc vous avez fait votre service
militaire dans la région étrangère vous
avez eu une aventure avec un sergent un
ancien de lindo qui était le fils
naturel du général de Gaulle
ça ne se fait pas beaucoup non
effectivement c'est comme quoi c'est
comme notre vrai nom
et alors mais quand on sait lire entre
les lignes des articles de fonds
alors au début du splendide j'étais
gigolo pour pour payer les travaux vous
en avez souffert de ça ça vous a humilié
non je ne crache pas dans la soupe
j'ai rendu heureux croyez-moi
j'ai fait un film porno le Prophète
premier film en fait c'est un film porno
avec Brigitte Lahaie vous avez une
aventure de plusieurs mois avec elle et
elle dit elle dit vous quand elle parle
de vous elle dit il aurait pu être un
super Rocco Siffredi là je peux pas
répondre à cette question
votre votre boîte échangiste préférée à
Paris en ce moment c'est quoi
c'est je sais pas tout ah chez bateau
alors vous êtes Hélène elle prend
comment votre aventure avec Claire Keim
pendant le tournage du film Le Roman de
Lulu voilà une habitude énorme
oui c'est bien
elle supporte que vous vous aviez quand
même de temps en temps à la maison parce
que c'est plus dur pour elle le dimanche
à midi
vous êtes un grand ami de Jean-Marie Le
Pen vous êtes pas désolé un petit peu
par la disparition du Front national du
paysage politique français ils se sont
gâchés vraiment
quand on a des quand on est des bons
amis comme ça ce ce brouiller pour une
histoire de cul c'est en fait
[Applaudissements]
des anciens du splendide vous
investissez beaucoup dans les 0 Center
dans dans le nord de l'Europe et vous
avez une spécialité c'est la Russie
des camions de russe en fait des films
qui bêtement on a mis en Yougoslavie qui
vient de se faire incarcérer mais très
bêtement fournissait c'était sympa mais
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont le plus les
filles de l'Est pourquoi vous voulez
vous faites venir par camion par wagon
entier ils sont sincères
elle compte pas alors vous avez déclaré
je voudrais mourir comme Elvis Presley
bourré de tranquillisant bourré de
sucreries en train de sauter des Lolita
vous maintenez ça oui ah oui c'est une
sorte d'apothéose vous essayez de
chanter comme Elvis et tout ça c'est que
pour moi et non un bon et les Russes et
les Lolita
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu